i'm hugh mangum chef and co-founder of
mighty quinn's barbecue here in new york
city and here are six must try items at
our restaurant
our brisket is all natural angus we
season it liberally there's a little
paprika in the rub and then we smoke it
for about 18 to 22 hours depending on
the brisket very simple there's no
hidden tricks here you know brisket in
general is one of the toughest cuts of
meat to smoke properly it's got a lot of
inter muscular fat and it's also two
muscles that are meeting which is the
point and the flat of the brisket so
you've got two different directions of
meat essentially going across the grain
in different sections so our brisket is
probably the single most important cut
of meat at mighty quinn's it's what
built the house we serve our brisket on
its own because we think it should sing
on its own and once you get into it it
should be nice and juicy and moist
crispy spicy chicken sandwich
our chicken breasts we dredge them with
a secret dredge and then they're fried a
crispy golden brown delicious gbd served
on a brioche roll cucumbers creamy
coleslaw and then chicken and it's like
you've got that secret sauce it's all in
the secret sauce basically you're
hitting all of the flavor components on
the spectrum sweet salty spicy creamy
umami bomb crispy mummy bum that's the
new name of the sandwich
burnt ends are chunks of the brisket
that we have removed and or cut and have
been smoked once again
uh so they're double smoked and then
they're tossed in our house sauce the
burnt ends are not technically burnt
they just have more of that outer bark
so i enjoy that smoky char
getting met with
that kind of sauce that reduces under
the heat so you have kind of like you
know sticky sweet meat salty smoke works
out really well
dirty fries they're just our hand-cut
fries which are twice fried and awesome
just on their own tossed with some of
the smaller bits of the burnt ends and
then we hit that with the wing sauce red
onions and then scallions that was our
go-to nightly adventure for our
executive chef alex stanko and myself
our plate of choice at one in the
morning when we were closing down the
restaurant you know with a beer
flavor bomb flavor
bomb
the brontosaurus rib so the bronzo rib
is a full plate short rib seasoned the
exact same way as the briskets and then
they are smoked typically 12 hours we
don't sauce all of our meats at mighty
quinns but we glaze certain things just
because we think certain things benefit
from that and then we remove the center
bone and one plate makes two portions
brisket built the house brancho broke
the internet it's massive each rib
weighs pound to a pound and a half of
meat on the bone it's a very unctuous
cut of meat fatty falling apart like a
braised wood and you can save the bone
to fend off would-be attackers when you
leave the restaurant
pumpkin bread pudding currently we're
running our pumpkin bread pudding which
is seasonal we're using all natural
pumpkin puree milk eggs vanilla sugar
cream
and spices our bread pudding is made
with our brioche rolls we toss that all
together and let it sit and we bake it
off and we top it with a
cinnamon creme on glaze it's our
seasonal bread pudding for the fall and
going into winter it should have a nice
crust on the outer topping of the
pudding itself but once you get into it
it should be nice and juicy and moist
oh yes
[Music]
you